[Musica]
dieci minuti con voi 5 km tecnica
classica equivale a questo un saluto
grazie per essere qui è bello essere con
tutti voi e con tutti voi per me tutto è
iniziato semplicemente in un luogo dove
io sono nata in via del bosco nel bosco
in mezzo alle montagne della carnia dove
d'inverno c'è tanta neve e dove a 4 anni
e mezzo circa
ho cercato di andare a prendere quelli
scettiche mio padre mi aveva preparato e
prima di condividere con lui
ufficialmente la prima sciata mio padre
allenatore gaetano io non sono stata
capace di trattenere me stessa ho preso
con gli scetti lì o infilati e sono
partita era la mia primissima esperienza
chiaramente in un mondo nuovo in un
mondo che mi ha cominciato a insegnare
ad ascoltare ad avere il moccolo che
cadeva giu
a sentire un freddo cane a non capire
più dove andavano gli sci dove andavano
i miei piedi a ritrovarmi per terra
subito dopo congelata a cominciare a
frignare io dover abbandonare quegli sci
per andare poi a piedi a raggiungere mio
padre che stava al forno e faceva il
pane
allora mio padre mi disse mai più una
cosa così quando si comincia una cosa
sera cominci a fare deve arrivare fino
in fondo e con un tono sostenuto ma
accettabile
io imparare la lezione
poi mia madre invece mi diede due
scappellotti quelli furono diversi ma
lasciamo perdere
ma quel giorno oltre alle parole
oltre a ciò che era successo oltre a
tutti questi fatti una cosa bella era
successo dentro di me che in quei pochi
passi con quegli sci con quel moccolo
che veniva giù con quel freddo forte io
ho sentito il mio cuore ho sentito che
quella elemento quella neve quel freddo
quel sole quel blu intenso di quel cielo
erano gli elementi che io amavo che mi
piacevano un sacco
io quella cosa lì la amano e piaceva da
morire e lì ho cominciato a dire questo
è il mio sogno fare qualche cosa di
bello con quella cosa lì e da lì ho
cominciato a seguire quello che erano
chiaramente le orme di un allenatore di
mio padre con la società sportiva ero
piccolissima e li atleti atlete
seguivano seguono ancora adesso sono
ancora là
le nuove generazioni i loro sogni come
io seguivo il mio sogno e gli atleti
maschi femmine tutti insieme si sciava
si stava insieme si giocava eravamo noi
stessi io ero me stessa poi a un certo
punto diventi signorina quell'età in cui
sei un po così e allora capisci che
qualcosa cambia capisci che qualcosa è
diverso perché le persone ti dicono cose
diverse perché ti dicono magari che devi
comportarti in modo diverso le bambine
non fanno questo sono solo i maschi
maschi poi devono allenarsi di più le
femmine devono levarsi di meno non mio
padre ma gli altri dicevano così e
allora ti rendi conto che veramente
qualcosa cambia
e veramente dentro di te
quello che da viper normale tutto quello
che facevi improvvisamente da quello che
chiamiamo la società ha modo di essere
la scuola i parenti anche ti dicono tu
non puoi fare una signorina non fa
quelle cose poi una signorina non deve
fare quegli sforzi una signorina è una
signorina allora io chiesi a mio padre
papà gli chiesi niente cioè richiesi
fanno gli chiesi però lui rispose papà
cosa devo fare
non ho fatto la domanda ma cosa devo
fare
cosa succede mio padre mi rispose noi
parliamo la lingua friulana apache
succede mio padre mi rispose come come
prime adesso come prima e questo adesso
come prima mi ha cambiato il mondo ha
cambiato allora il mondo e lo cambia
ancora adesso dentro di me perché mi ha
creato il nucleo fondante della mia
libertà perché quel giorno quando io ho
capito che non era uguale agli altri ai
maschi soprattutto che c'era qualcosa di
diverso
ho anche capito che non ero libera ho
anche capito che non potevo essere
libera ma perché non ero libera di fare
quello che volevo
perché mi dicevano che lo sci nordico
era uno sport da duri dove si diventava
brutti brutali e poi una donna non può
essere così una donna deve essere molto
bene
deve essere sempre a posto ma è sudata
per essere stato ma il mio sogno
comprendeva anche se volevo uscire se
volevo fare qualche cosa di bello con
gli sci e sulla neve
io dovevo prepararmi dovevo sudare
dovevo sporcarmi i vestiti di sudore di
di di quello che è un lavoro che bisogna
fare allora come potevo fare questo
belle parole di mio padre mi hanno
creato il nucleo fondante della libertà
di poter essere me stessa la libertà di
seguire un mio percorso che poi sin da
piccola è stato un percorso non ad
ostacoli di più che ad ostacoli
un percorso dove giorno per giorno non
solo lo sport ma soprattutto il vivere
comune l'andare a scuola ti dicevano ma
no tu non farai mai quello spore intanto
è uno sport per maschi
poi è uno sport le italiane in quello
sport non esistono perché uno sport per
russe ma avete mai visto le russe come
sono le rosse io non ho mai visto le
russe no e questo non ho mai visto le
russe melo sono ricordata quando io
quelle russe le ho viste e le ho viste
bene e le ho viste ancora quando avevano
anche la falce il martello ancora dietro
la schiena cccp e come li ho visto già
perso 30 secondi in gara perché ci aveva
una cosa forte qui perché erano le russe
ma quel giorno quando io sul percorso in
una gara ho sentito che anche le russe
puzzavano mi sono detta sta a vedere che
anche le russe fanno fatica che anche le
russe sono come me
e allora da quel giorno anche le russe
sono arrivate seconde
ma i pregiudizi i pregiudizi
il 3d giudizi attraverso cui un atleta
deve passare una donna deve passare sono
talmente belli che a un certo punto ho
deciso di coccolare mele tutti perché
attraverso tutti questi pregiudizi più
c'era qualcuno che mi diceva no quello
non è per te dico questa energia per
fare è un'energia per fare allora a un
certo punto quando è indubbiamente
portando avanti quello che vuoi fare
nella vita quello che vuoi essere e
soprattutto voler arrivare piedi quello
che normalmente chiedono tutti chiedono
la squadra maschile avevano bella
squadra gli allenatori tecnici la
squadra femminile stava nascendo squadra
femminile di sci nordico ovviamente
chiaramente non avevamo tanti tecnici
non avevamo allenatori eravamo la
squadretta femminile beh così forse non
si riesce a vincere più di tanto
quindi io chiesi di allenarmi con la
squadra maschile perché per me il
maschio la femmina non c'è differenza
l'atleta è quello che vuole esprimere il
massimo di se stesso e questa non sta
nello nella caratteristica del sesso sta
nella caratteristica della persona che
deve esprimere quello che di massimo lei
deve esprimere quindi io dico io voglio
andare nel gruppo più bravo che sia
maschio o femmina ma il gruppo che più
mi insegna e quindi accettare di andare
e chiesi e loro accettarono di
dimettermi in questa squadra maschile
chiaramente questo fu un percorso
bellissimo un percorso che mi portò
anche tra l'altro prima di iniziare
l'ingresso di entrare a iniziare
l'ingresso nella squadra mi portò anche
a passare un grande periodo nelle terre
finlandesi nelle terre e finlandesi dove
questo allenatore finlandese occhi di
ghiaccio grande persona voleva testarmi
psicologicamente e li arrivata oltre il
circolo polare
e artico mi disse tu allenare qui tutto
giorno e di non aver problema io
allenare tutto giorno peccato che non
avevo capito che lapponia cioè lì c'è il
sole 365 cioè nell'anno sei mesi sono
sole 24 ore su 24
quindi tutto giorno era tutto giorno al
di là di questo però alla fine arrivò
dopo un po di giorni l'allenatore e mi
disse tu adesso parlare con me sono
pronta
mi guardò negli occhi e mi disse tu
volere fare piccolo a casa o grande casa
che dico io
io parto da paluzza in provincia di
udine
ho il mio sogno voglio fare qualcosa di
bello nello sport io dentro di me dico
caro qui mi gioco tutto io volere fare
che ratta cielo
e da lì questo grattacielo mi ha
insegnato chiaramente ma veramente che
ci vogliono gli ingegneri che ci
vogliono i tecnici che ci vogliono
quindi gli allenatori che ci vuole il
gruppo tu esprimi te stessa
singolarmente in gara ma poi c'è tutto
il gruppo che è con te in gara e tu sei
con loro nei box o sul percorso e questa
è la forza che io mi sono trascinata
quando ero io su quelli sci mi
trascinavo la loro forza sui miei sci
ecco questo è stato un lavoro bellissimo
di gruppo che io ho fatto e essere
libere di un gruppo così soprattutto
negli ultimi anni è stata una cosa
bellissima è stata una cosa che mi ha
arricchita dentro in una maniera
meravigliosa e condividere col mio
gruppo ma ancora di più condividere con
le persone che mi hanno sempre seguita
del mio percorso sportivo soprattutto
quelle non sportive quelle persone a che
hanno capito che anche a volte da
momenti di grande difficoltà come io ho
avuto quando per esempio mi trovava in
un ospedale e quando succede che tutti i
giornalisti anche t dimenticano che
esisti che sei una grande campionessa in
quel momento hai anche dei problemi
in quei momenti li ti ricordi quali sono
le vere persone che contano e che devono
far parte della tua squadra perché
contano e ti rendi conto quelle che non
contano ma quando hai fatto il di
riferimento tra questi e 26 ancora più
libera per dire che comunque quando sei
su quelli sci quando esprime quello che
è il tuo amore per quella cosa e quindi
dà il massimo di te stessa
in quella cosa allora ti senti anche
privilegiata perché hai la possibilità
di poterlo fare per tutti quelli
che anche da casa che anche da lontano
ti seguono ma soprattutto sono a
condividere con te la tua bandiera al
tuo paese la tua nazione il tuo senso di
appartenenza a quel mondo che il mondo
dell'italia al mondo del tricolore
appunto il mondo di gente che ti guarda
e tu sei lì a gareggiare anche per loro
perché tu li rappresenti questo è uno
dei privilegi più belli più grandi più
forti
la condivisione con la tua nazione
e poi io ho cominciato con un sogno fare
qualche cosa di bello nello sport
poi i sogni chiaramente ai sogni vanno
aggiunti quelli che sono dei pezzi
importanti in primis il cuore perché
deve metterci tantissimo cuore e poi
devi metterci tutto quello che è la tua
capacità di amare non solo quello che la
parte tecnica dello sci ma di amare
tutto quello che quello sci esprime
nella storia nella cultura nella
diversità dei popoli nella cultura
diversa del esprimere e questa è stata
credo la mia medaglia più bella
raccogliere questo
[Applauso]
[Musica]